none of the elites wore masks in their
seats
well that would be weird if they did
actually
they'll put your rights in a squeeze
while they do whatever they please
everyone from la mayor eric garcetti to
some fella named lebron to a bunch of
actors i didn't recognize are being
called out for defying the mask rules at
the super bowl even ellen degeneres who
took hers off only so she could spit on
foreign and former employees
and foreign ones
that's not true she's a delightful
person we're getting brunch tomorrow
it's almost like people are realizing
the safety theater was just that theater
except the actors in the show no longer
want to play their roles the city health
department repeatedly noted that all
attendees would be required to wear a
mask inside the stadium they even gave
up upgraded kn 95 masks perfect for when
you want to cheer and soak in your own
drool
but none complied clearly and they
shouldn't have to wear masks except it
makes them all
hypocrites when you consider the fact
that kids in california still have to
mask up in school and the kids will have
to still wear masks even after
california's mandate is lifted on
tuesday i guess the feeling is
if they were attractive their parents
could afford private school am i right
[Laughter]
but it raises a question with their
faces covered how will the kids learn to
judge each other by race
i bet the left
i bet the left did not think of that did
they
[Laughter]
so uh chadwick may i call you chadwick
yeah yeah you may or chad hey you know i
or wick which is better all right rick
is better do you notice how now they're
redefining the definition of freedom
it's like now freedom is like oh
freedom's great until you infringe but
then they define what the infringement
is so if you're like not wearing a mask
across the street you're infringing on
my rights i don't have to wear the mask
but you not wearing one is an
infringement right yeah yeah uh and uh
yeah it's i'm taking away your freedom
to feel safe in your what is yeah yeah
you you it's um it's gone from my rules
uh dictate what freedom means well look
like the truckers right you know and how
the with the protests um well they're
they're tyrants and their fascists
because they're demanding more rights
yes exactly yeah how does that work
exactly yeah and that picture of ellen
degeneres i legit thought that was
justin bieber at first well you know
he's looking terrible well she's she
looks i think she's quite an attractive
woman but so is justin bieber he is a
very attractive woman he's very
attractive woman uh tegan
can i say that i mean i don't you know
that i don't see gender i just don't see
any gender at all
i'll sleep with a mannequin yeah you
just say like
luscious eyebrows what is um i know that
we were talking about this in the
breakdown
we have to almost retire the word
hypocrisy because we get nowhere with it
right so what do we say what can we do
we just have to say you're not wearing
masks we're not wearing masks uh
sanctimonious ass crack there you go
uh like charlize theron
i
these celebrities have been
hankering to not wear these masks for a
couple of years because really you know
at the end of the day you can always
count on them did i just say end of the
day i'm sorry yes it's okay um you can
always count on them to be
needy
desperate attention [ __ ]
so they're not going to go to the super
bowl
and sit in a box and wear a bathroom and
wear a mouse because what what if the
audience at home doesn't recognize them
yeah
that is just
what is the point they might as well
just be
sorry and sit at home yeah we saw this
coming didn't we cat we knew this was
going to happen that's why we ended the
whole pandemic february 1st because we
said like we're just going to run head
first into the super bowl yeah last
night on my way home from the bar i did
not wear a mask wow and that was because
i lost it
i'm gonna say now it was for the kids uh
there you go it was for i'm re-write
it's for the kids because honestly all
the time there's obviously different
rules for adults than for like toddlers
and i think that's good
but usually that's because we don't
think a toddler could handle things yeah
now we're expecting them to handle more
i just feel whoever made this rule that
a two-year-old has to wear a mask they
should have had to meet a two-year-old
first right exactly exactly
judge uh you know we covered this on the
five what more what more can you add to
this scintillating topic well probably
not a lot except here's the issue is
that
those people who are in politics and
those celebrities who may be unmasking
so they can be seen in the public forum
um they just think that they're better
than the rest of us that's true and
maybe they are judged i don't think so
and i think that they believe that they
don't have to follow the rules because
they're the upper class and we're the
peons when it comes to politicians we
put them in office how dumb are we but i
think the saddest part of it all is that
the weakest of everyone the children are
left having to wear masks in school and
outside of school on the playgrounds i
mean that's really all about the fact
that they don't have power and i think
we should give the power to the to the
kids yeah it's it's like a virtue signal
that you place on somebody else right
it's like
uh
those kids should be wearing masks there
i did my business now i don't have to
wear one but as long as i force other
people to follow it therefore i am
actually virtue signaling by some kind
of abstraction yeah you know it's like
saying that if you're a jerk actress as
long as you claim that you're for the
right cause you can still be for the you
could still be a jerk to everybody i
mean harvey weinstein that was his
entire career everybody knew what he did
right but he did nothing but liberal
causes which created a moat to protect
him from all the perversions there's one
video of a woman on an airplane and she
doesn't have her mask on and she's
fighting with an 80 year old guy you've
seen this and then and the flight
attendant says put your mask on she said
you heard her put your mask on she
doesn't have a mask on yeah and the
flight attendant says you put your mask
on he's got do you hear that put your
mask on and that woman was scarlett
johansson
[Laughter]
right no
there was a chance i could be right
all right she was actually a former
cheerleader right now oakland raiders
i'm just thinking about scarlet
johansson's mouth never mind okay
sometimes up next
will weak da's never say enough and put
criminals back in cuffs hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else